[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue à non touche
pas à mon j'ai failli atteint cyril nous
a dit qu'il serait pas là aujourd'hui
il la cherche et qui pourrait le
remplacer alors il a trouvé le summum
avec bernard à prendre ou à laisser de
vous et moi où tu arrives à ma kelly
kelly je compte sur toi tu veux à mon
secours dès que tu peux je ne parle même
pas je t'aime mais je te parle même pas
géraldine on va parler tennis chez toi
mais je compte sur toi francesca on a
vécu tellement de choses avec fabrice
car en tunisie qu une chamelle je te
raconte pas évident les chamelles excuse
on a été obligé de lire les noms des
gens pour savoir men on a le droit de
rire un peu à lui pas vu et comme je
pouvais pas le faire après eh ben tu ben
bella est justement on me pose souvent
la question parce que j'ai un truc en
plus de ce reportage c'est qu'on me dit
souvent mais pourquoi tu veux mettre
quelques chars va pas gêner on va
regarder
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les féministes me pardonne mais ça
s'appelle un avion de chasse alors vous
voulez je m'attendais pas parce que vous
le fassiez je suis un peu ému et ça me
fait bizarre je crois le souligne avait
rajeuni depuis encore et ce soir les
assauts heureux de vous retrouver parce
qu'on m'avait manqué ça fait depuis
jeudi que j'ai quitté l'antenne mais les
gens se poser des questions hanouna et
au et il n'a pas quitté ses huit hanouna
va-t-il quitter le paf hanouna va-t-il
arrêter de nous emmerder
beaucoup de gens étaient heureux encore
malheureusement hanouna est de retour
veillez à luna is back
c'est l'anti zabel regarder isabelle
morini-bosc vanité isabelle 12 hier vous
avez pris les commandes de thé pmp
d'ailleurs bravo avec brio vous avez été
excellent je regrette c'est que je les
dis à tous les chroniqueurs bernard oui
cela avait désigné pour lui mais moi je
pense y être tout seul je les lis plus
au bout de cinq minutes
mais si on m'avait dit une autre
avec isabelle parole je pense qu il
était une fois c'est cette personne de
rené lui passe son temps à dire je m'en
bats les couilles hossa mangement bats
les couilles
mais sauf oui moi mon run un moment faut
les sortir foulée posé sur la table
bah ouais
justement je les ai posé calton ses
stats pas capable de trucs du genre on
ne le fait pas si c'est pour faire un
peu de compagnie est avec nous ce soir
je l' ai toujours dit ici et vous pouvez
pas dire le contraire oui un jour eh
ouais c'est mon actrice préférée est
avec nous c'est dire si nul au doigt de
kate avait couvert les chars déjà si on
m'avait dit un jour que je verrai et
virginie ledoyen en face de rooney ç'a
déjà les interviews pour voir si tu
connais mieux leonardo dicaprio mois
vous pouvez l'aider également attention
leonardo dicaprio one one hanouna vous
jouez également chez vous lequel des
deux a débuté sa carrière en jouant dans
une pub pour des chewing gum à l'âge de
12 ans leonardo dicaprio ou hanouna je
dirais toi non et non bernardo dicaprio
il m'avait proposé avant que ce qu'on
avait un peu plus il avait refusé pour
les dents je ne veux pas mettre mes
dents péril dans la
lequel des deux aurait franche
franchement mérité l'oscar dicaprio pour
titanic ou hanouna pour la vérité si je
mens 3 en termes de présence à l'écran
on va dire dit qu'après parce qu'il est
plus longtemps dans titanic
ça me déçoit beaucoup non mais la bonne
intensité les deux
[Musique]
il revient is back il revient d'une
tournée triomphale dans tout le nord de
guingamp maxime dillies tous avec toi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
stan wawrinka qui m'appellent par mon
frère où seule antenne
[Rires]
[Musique]
ouais tu me manques ont des brise tout
de suite oublier non non non non ça va
te coucher tu ne peux pas taper après
l'émission pourquoi des briques vraiment
parce que moi pour moi je vais te dire
tout est parfait et un bas bien sûr
d'eux mais je vais t'appeler après quand
même parce qu'il ya deux trois petites
choses à revoir
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
du coup
également m
pas vrai ouais j'ai pensé je vous dis
qu'à celles à arrêter quoi patrick fiori
habib sy n attendait que vous êtes
sortait patrimoine oui mais genre
pendant combien de temps à peine un mois
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
attention
peu touché michael jordan est alors il
n'ya pas michael jordan ici c'est bon
merci je sens que ça va être très beau
sur vous attention la veine du cabinda
qui va me servir y compris c'est ça
bravo est maintenant un petit peu de
fromage si assez bon mais bon tout ça
c'était lassant c'est vrai on va aller
[ __ ] au four
à pizza merci à tous d'avoir est avec
nous
regardez les
[Applaudissements]
surtout je voulais en partir
flickr c'est bon
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est l'anniversaire de la petite chérie
mais s'il vous plaît que je peux faire
une égale ou this et isabelle ma chérie
d'amour
et il y à côté une salle pleine de
cadeaux peau de personnes qui vont avoir
trente secondes pour aller récupérer le
plus de cadeaux possibles pour prenez
les plus sportifs à mon avis vous pouvez
même choisir des points d'entrée sportif
m'a forcément c'est vous parce que les
autres si je regarde pas
[Rires]
ça
les points
je m'en prendre eux qui même s'il est
avachi a tellement bien sa grande gueule
déjà depuis le début je voulais choisir
c'est jean-michel l'espagne le brésil et
sportivement mais il avait juste à me
passer fléchi apparemment on a 30
secondes pour aller dans cette salle
magnifique où il ya tous les cadeaux à
temps
[Applaudissements]
c
art
[Applaudissements]
je suis absolument pas d'accord une
personne qui essentialise elle est
devant la justice et à les condamner à
ce jour il n'y a pas de féministes il
n'y a pas d' antiracistes qui est
médiatique qui était condamné pour des
propos les propos déformés déréglé mot
hommage aux justes adressé un hameau à
christine que j'apprécie beaucoup et
dont j'admire énormément la carrière
vraiment j'ai beaucoup d'estimé pour la
trajectoire que vous avez pu avoir
et franchement moi quand je vous vois
face à eric zemmour qui tient des propos
mais abject écoeurant qui s'en prend à
des personnes en raison de leur culture
en raison de leur couleur de peau
j'ai vraiment l'impression vous méritait
beaucoup mieux que ça que vous méritez
vraiment d'avoir face à vous une
personne qui soit respectueuse les
autres êtres humains et quand je vous
vois vous débattre prendre la haine chic
chic chic ne vous ai même pas destiné
mais qui est provoqué par ses propos
ça me désole pour la journaliste que
vous êtes je trouve que vous avez
vraiment tellement de choses à montrer
tellement de talent à à mettre au
service d'un autre type de propos que ça
le fait ça me fait de la peine vraiment
je suis désolé de devoir ce talent là au
service dans le service mantica
permettre à de tels propos de se
répondre jour après jour et vendredi
parce que j'ai beaucoup d'affection et
beaucoup d'admiration pour ce que vous
achetiez sous préfète en tant que
journaliste
[Musique]